[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want
and on today's segment ask an expert we
have don here
who is a former marine raider which is
part of special
operations and so we uh used to talk a
lot when we were training
for the marathon and we'd just be
running like
seven nine ten miles so we just have
like conversations
and i would hear some of the craziest
stories and i'm like what the [ __ ]
like one of them was um can you tell
them about the one where
you you're in a helicopter accident and
it like slammed you against the ground
oh yeah yeah wait what
yeah actually this is crazy it's just
crazy to just hear them yeah we were
um training in arizona so we were
supporting um
the marine version of like top gun
pretty much it's called wti it's like
weapon tactics instructor
for all the pilots in the marine corps
but for them to get like certified they
need to support
a ground unit so we were like the
makeshift ground unit
the special operations team that was
training in other forces coming in um
so anyway it's kind of like role playing
a little bit yeah role-playing
larping yeah but people die and get
injured
in military larping all the time right
yes unfortunately yeah
um but for this specific scenario we
were supposed to go do a
insert at night time and we were flying
on ch-53s which is like the really big
helicopters um it's like the ones that
carry trans
the transformers in and transformers oh
hell yeah dude yeah
um but one of the sensors was coming out
so we were kind of
on the final approach for landing i
think the ground sensor was out
so when he was coming into the landing
he
the front rotors or the top rotors hit
the building in front of them
like in the movie like yeah i could hit
the building
and it was like sliding forward and as
soon as that happened
it lost control so the back tail of the
aircraft was bouncing back and forth
and me and my friend was unhooked
because we get the 30 seconds call we're
supposed to get ready to drop the ramp
and help everybody out
so we're just slamming up and down on
top of the back ramp until the
aircraft's strapping the
tail rotor actually ended up breaking
off oh [ __ ]
yeah and it cracked open and then you
guys could see nothing but air and [ __ ]
well it was pitch black
and we had night vision on but our
partner nation force which is
other marines didn't have it so like we
were like oh [ __ ] we got to get off this
helicopter
right now so we're trying to get people
off and they were about to walk into the
tail rotor oh [ __ ] yeah but
luckily we pulled them off because you
could see right we had night vision on
and they did it
is the pilot in training too like what's
these are supposed to be the best pilots
in the marine corps they're going
through a course to get certified as
instructors
um pretty much did he i mean does he
fail because of that i mean
i'm pretty sure yeah yeah there was like
a whole investigation right no one died
no no but wasn't that a that's a
mechanical malfunction right but he
should have prepped for that you should
prep for it and he should have
understood that the sensor was out and
then accounted for it because a lot of
times when helicopters land it's uh we
call it brown out
scenarios so so much dirt kicks off the
ground that
it floods out their sensors sometimes so
he should have been able to
kind of adapt to that situation so he
put everyone's lives in danger
for sure damn that's crazy what kind of
injuries did you have from that
i had a concussion like my neck was
swollen just from slamming up and down
were you when you get slammed up and
down were you like knocked out were you
just laying on the floor no
i was not knocked out i was i thought i
was gonna die though i peed myself a
little bit i'm not gonna lie oh shh
but i mean being in a air like v
like any type of flight and you're just
going up and down you hit the top of the
airplane or anything bottom hit the top
that's like
boom like that right like a cartoon yeah
i mean i i didn't know if we were back
in the air or if we were on the ground
or what was going on it was just
because you couldn't see anything oh my
god yeah and how many people were in
there with you going up and down
it was only me and my other buddy that
was nazi built in yeah oh
[ __ ] that's crazy and then when you go
home that night do you go like why the
[ __ ] did i do this
i just want to know what happened or did
you go to the hospital that night do you
get x-rays or like yeah we went to like
that bass or whatever and she got
checked out did you change your pee pee
pants
i didn't change it until afterwards oh
[ __ ] it was only a little bit though oh
okay that's like a little dribble
did you ask the other guy if you had a
little dribble too yeah he did too
it's natural though dude oh dude i would
[ __ ] myself straight up
i think i would just die or some [ __ ]
i'd quit i quit the military after that
holy [ __ ] dude when people are you're
not on an airplane and somebody's
freaking out about turbulence you're
just like
yo shut the [ __ ] up yeah dude military
helicopter accidents and flight
accidents happened so many times i had
like
there's two marine raiders flights one
helicopter that went down they
lost everybody another one like a
uh c-130 just blew up in mid-air lost
everybody
like two both in training yeah both in
training marine raider teams ah
same team number whoa same pilot
no i can't that's why i know
yeah crazy it's the same dumbass
that crashed the helicopter well you get
one more chance to okay two more chances
yeah so like i'm assuming that
everything happens like in baby steps
right where like you go to boot camp you
go to all these different
things and then your tolerance for what
is crazy to the normal person
becomes normal right like uh so like
when you're out in combat and all these
things like
is there ever a time where you get used
to it because i'm hearing like
you're just used to like bullets going
you're just like
not calm but you're used you get used to
it i don't know how to explain
um well i guess you're just more
familiar with
the effects of that whatever situation
you are so like hey if you're getting
shot at
um if you don't hear like that when the
sound breaks or the round breaks a sound
barrier and it's like snapping by you
like you know when you're at the range
and you hear all those snaps
pass you you know it's close so you know
you should put your head down but if
you just hear rounds like coming past
you and it's not and it's already dying
down
you're like okay maybe it's not accurate
fire coming at me maybe i can take a
second
make sure i know what's going on with
the situation and then get down and get
covered
in the beginning though like breaking
your first cherry in combat world right
were you screaming because i would have
been screwed but ah son of a
[ __ ] i hope all my training would be
working but i think i don't know like
it's the first time
and in the first time did you go as
infantry or did you go as special ops
infantry yeah i was 18 in iraq the first
time but
18 yeah you were 18 when you saw combat
but i pretty much like blacked out
oh ish what do you mean like you forgot
yeah i can't remember
remember much of it because he was just
such a shock so scared
so so much adrenaline pumping you know
like
so where what is your background like
like um
you're bored here or yeah i was born and
raised in long beach california
and then did you like grow up seeing
violence or anything like that
um i mean i grew up in long beach so
there's a lot of violence around you
um but i mean my dad
was an asian dad yeah he beat the hell
out of youtube yeah i got
jumped a few times in high school but
not like nothing no gang violence no
like [ __ ] gun shooting
in high school or anything so the first
time you actually saw
combat gunshots all that was in war
yeah oh damn do you think boot camp oh
actually no i did get shot at in high
school
yeah okay so but because usually i ask
this question because like people that
have been around it
like they're it's not their first rodeo
right like
when these it's different from like
someone that came from a nice little
town cause i'm
only imagine like the world war ii like
draft kids that are
18 years old they came from like a good
little home and then all of a sudden
boom they're in combat yeah
so it's like that must be crazy well
there's people that like even at boot
camp
they're just crying already for real
yeah just because you're just not used
to like that kind of intensity of people
yelling at your face moving at that
speed you know it's just like
there's there's already people that are
like freaking the [ __ ] out and then
you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm kind of glad my parents yelled at me
so how yes so let's start from there
like how did how was boot camp for you
like did you take it easy or was it like
hard it was the hardest thing i did at
the time
and then every i mean it gets harder and
harder it gets harder and harder yeah
but if you the battle is already hard
and you know you have to go through some
other
selection or some school don't you go oh
[ __ ] that's gonna be harder than that
one now i'm good but i mean
some of the like the challenges is also
like an adrenaline rush
you know so you kind of try to go and
focus and do some more of it
um and i think that's why people join
the military like they like the
adrenaline rush
pretty much so what was your mission in
iraq that first
thing you had to do um that was counter
terrorism or
what they call it coin counter
insurgency but
pretty much that one was drive over the
ieds or the bombs
and try to find the bad guys if you can
drive over them
well i mean we just drove over so we
drove over like 15 or
16. yeah some of them weren't big enough
blew up the front of
the vehicles but no one died
oh no no one died in that one but my
friend jeremy burris died on that
deployment
um yeah he drove over one and then he
left his glasses
in the truck and then he went back to
his truck to grab the glasses
then when he jumped out of the truck he
stepped on the secondary one oh
wow yeah so the first time you were you
basically
grew up most of your adult life in
combat then
yeah in the military yeah like yeah like
18 is still hella young
if you think about it yeah and then you
start seeing
you know you have bullets being shot at
you all this stuff and it's weird to me
how like um you know you get deployed
and then you come back to civilian world
and then you go back
and then it's just this crazy difference
man like how do you deal with that
difference well after coming back from
that first deployment from iraq it was
like
the best thing flying back coming back
to america like i was appreciating
everything
you know like looking at a girl do you
appreciate that because everything's
all the female in the middle east are
mostly covered or iraq and afghanistan
yeah
so you saw like their ankles maybe
that's a nice ankle you know
so you're like a horny 18 year old and
you're just like i need to see a woman
there aren't that many other females in
the military not in the infantry
all right right now there's no none with
us at those operating bases or anything
like that for the most part um but yeah
and like back then there was like one
satellite phone for your whole platoon
you get one call every two weeks one
five minute call every two weeks wow
so like now but like even overseas now
anywhere you go you have some type of
cell phone reception or some type of
internet so everyone can have cell
phones
if the yeah everybody has like their
host nation phone so you can still talk
to like the host your partner nation
commanders or whatever it is you
still talk to them but it still talks
back to america i'm pretty sure for the
most part
this episode of off the record is
brought to you by hbo
max hbo max is a streaming platform that
bundles
all of the hbo stuff together in one
place
there's iconic movies big big big tv
shows like friends
fresh prince of bel air euphoria some of
the best stuff
out there you know um something that i'm
about to do
this cozy romantic season because i'm
all alone
what i'm gonna binge watch a show by
myself i haven't done it in so long
and it's one of those like guilty kind
of pleasures that i have
yeah and i know the world does it but i
just feel so ashamed
that i do it too tell you what watch
shows by yourself
over and over and over sometimes that's
the best way to binge especially if
someone else doesn't have the endurance
yeah you can't hang if you want to watch
one season i mean uh one episode after
the other episode that's true and fresh
prince of bel air
is back baby so me and geo we were so
bored
that we're like damn no other show lives
up to the hype of game of thrones so you
know what we did
you started again we watched it again
hbo max hands down has the best shows on
the planet man
so right now new and returning
subscribers can sign up for a limited
time
by taking advantage of their prepay and
save offer to save
20 percent by pre-paying for the first
six months
of an hbo max subscription
offer ends march 1st 2021 and
restrictions do apply so you got to go
there fast hbo max has something for
everyone every day
check out the link in the description
and get 20 off the first prepaid 6
months of your hbo max subscription
thank you thank you what was the first
thing you did when you got home
from war with you really
yeah dude where sure i well i had a
girlfriend i'll run off
yeah beautiful yeah isn't that crazy
like
all guys in the car really it was really
like
five seconds or i bet whatever it was
yeah you were come on dude you had sand
backed up on your d
it was right when you got picked up yeah
oh that's tight you [ __ ] came at her
i'm looking at her no calves bro we saw
the ankles but with the calves
that's crazy yeah yeah eat good food in
and out
went to in and out what made you want to
go back
like because after all that you're just
like man this is crazy it wasn't until
like the second my second appointment to
iraq that i
wanted to do something more because the
first one was just in shock and
but then i still had to finish the rest
of my first enlistment
you know so it wasn't really my choice
so what does that mean um
you have a contract of a time you're
supposed to serve right
yeah and so when you get activated that
means your unit
is called to do the nation's duty and go
out to wherever it's deployed
exactly so you guys did the first tour
when you came back you were still on
contract to go back
exactly yeah so whatever your unit's
going next and you're still with that
unit it's
up to them where you're pretty much
going so you went back
and then you're just like all right but
what was it like going back the second
time was it easier
was it it was a lot easier um for sure
and uh i was a squad leader for the
second one so i was in charge of people
and then i
got to see more and then we actually did
a cordon so according like if you have
if someone's coming to uh do a hit on a
building
you're the force around that building to
make sure you isolate it no one comes in
and as well as
security forces yeah so you kind of
restrict the people coming out as well
and we had a navy seal
team come in and do a hit on that
building i'm actually at the
wrong building they hit the building
next to you're like hey hey guys it's
over here
fight me over here guys yeah pretty much
but that was like oh man these guys are
so cool you know they come in with like
tennis shoes cool guns
baseball hats you know like that's what
was like my first experience of like
special operations i was like and you're
like i want to do what they're doing do
what they're doing
you know and i'm out here sitting in the
truck waiting for these guys to hit the
building
but in my head i'm like i want to go in
there and shoot the bad guys
i want to go hit the wrong building yeah
they actually had their dog bite off
the calf of this girl that ripped her
cow oh [ __ ] and they
went to the next building hit the
building and then we had they left the
girl for us to deal with
that sucks yeah damn i'm sure there's a
lot of mistakes that happen in ward and
that
that just sucks but that's also like you
know when you're back
here that training it's almost like if
you play a game you know how like
they they almost feel like going to iraq
or going into theater
that's like game day so you know yeah so
when you're training
like when you're like running practice
like basketball or football practice
um that's what training bad guy here is
it's just that you're training with like
lethal forces and that's why people can
die during
practice and everything they do to train
you is always about like
oh kill kill kill you know it's like
it's kind of like
brainwashing in a type of way yeah i
mean you you are one ultimate goal
yeah like that's your job like it's a
warrior's job like you're not there to
make friends i was watching this like
documentary of um
was this sealed team six that hit osama
bin laden or no
like they they already knew the building
and then they really they built it right
so they knew exactly what the build they
got the blueprints they built the
building
and they spent like six months running
plays
pretty much right exactly wow did you
guys
in in the once you get to special
operations for your missions did you
guys have that kind of like
level of like rehearsal
not with my team uh specifically so when
i was in afghanistan we were um at
we had a mission called uh vso village
stability operations so they flew us in
uh and we put into a village that
there's americans or maybe
america's been there maybe we're placed
in a team where no americans have been
and you're pretty much
sent there to build a militia to defend
themselves from the taliban so how do
you become
friends with the locals to be like all
right we're here to help you guys out
so the taliban doesn't come over here um
whatever
like object objectives like their
village elders have we try to help them
out
and everybody wants them first yeah and
everybody doesn't want the taliban to
rip them off and take all their poppy or
whatever it is you know other farms and
stuff that so we talked to them and
stuff
but to answer your question real fast
there was another team that was part of
the commando team
um and all their jobs was to go out with
the afghan commandos and do hits
so whatever intel we would do unless we
were getting shot at first or if it was
a target that we
had um a better
reason to hit yeah like we're working
with this force and they hit it and they
won't work with anybody but us
then most time we were just turning over
the mission package to these other guys
that would come and hit and
they would build up mock-up buildings
and stuff like that and do rehearsals on
it
multiple times yeah then what was your
question
again i forgot how you can how do you
get along with the
local afghanistan oh yeah yeah like how
do you train them and all that stuff you
offer them a part of
mre i mean we got chocolates we
definitely give them
um offer them food training we pay them
to train so they have some type of
salary then we kind of get that
try to establish their own government
within the area so like hey kind of
a point like a village elder and then he
kind of appoints a military leader in
the town and just trying to build up
some type of governance
some sort of stability and stability
true that many
of those tribes have never even seen
like
other people in afghanistan yeah
afghanistan's a
crazy different dynamic because they've
just seen war for for so long
you know they've the russians were there
i mean just forever
um but like different parts of
afghanistan you see
different types of people that have been
through there like the tajiks in
afghanistan
they look straight mongolian you know
and then there's like another tribe
wherever they look
like russian descent and they're like
bright red hair
and like the bluest eyes like not like
red hair like gingers
in america but like red red like that
red
oh wow it's crazy and their eyes are
blue and not like the blues over here
it's like
uh sea blue like it's like a hawaii
ocean
like hawaii ocean some pure russian [ __ ]
yeah wow
it's crazy yeah and then the other ones
are like they look straight like middle
eastern
so it's just a different weird dynamic
wow that's crazy and when you go into
these villages
um is it because i you know for for
from me being living in a big city you
automatically assume
everyone has a similar understanding of
life right like i can go into a room i
know
if i need to take a piss there's a
toilet right like when you go into these
villages is it like does it sometimes
feel like you're
almost time traveling into like caveman
days like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
100
there's a lot of rural places in
afghanistan that haven't
have no tv have no i mean maybe they
have maybe they have like uh
some weird antenna or something like
that but very
limited cell phone reception whoa no
internet you know just like a regular
cell phone
um so how do you even like connect
um and then a lot of guys go to speak
pashu and ari before
they learn how to speak the language
before they go over there so we can kind
of understand and pick up some of this
stuff
and then the tribes also speak the same
language or like it just depends which
tribe
they're coming from as well but pascha
and dhari is a
dominant of the two um languages in
afghanistan yeah do they know why you're
there
i sometimes sometimes they do sometimes
yeah like do they know you're there to
help fight the bad guys like are they
just like
yeah but it's just a [ __ ] up system to
begin with you know like you kill the
taliban no one pays them
for their poppy you know and for a while
the america had a mission to
burn the poppy fields which is [ __ ]
not a good idea do they whatsoever know
what they're growing
is i guess illegal to us or no
they know it's drugs but they know that
they get to use they
so they know it's drugs and they know
that
by growing these drugs they get to make
money for their family
that's as as they pretty much boil down
as their logic is
yeah and do they even care that america
is like it's illegal in america probably
not
is it true that we also had uh forces
guarding the poppy fields as well
it just depends on whatever commanders
um and i
were in that time um what his mission
objectives were what his
you know people told them to do pretty
much but
sometimes there was to protect the field
sometimes it was to
burn them what's the incentive of
protecting the fields or what's inside
of the burning the fields
burning him because we didn't want the
money to fund the taliban anymore right
so that money
they would believe that it was it's true
taliban was taking the money and then
buying equipment weapons stuff to make
bombs protecting them
so that way they can still have a living
to be able to maintain the ecosystem
maintain their ecosystem it's not the
taliban's poppies it's the local
villages poppy
majority of the time they buy them from
the local villages right
yes exactly wow so the only people that
are buying the poppies are the taliban
there's no other people well the taliban
and then other organized
other [ __ ] terrorist organizations
like isis is heavily in afghanistan now
dang so it just depends but i mean it's
a huge
market yeah people are not going to stop
doing drugs and
unfortunately did you ever take any
selfies with poppies
i did not but i have some with weed
plants oh okay yeah
poppy was everywhere though so i didn't
think to taste oh special yeah
did you ever take any pictures with
saddam's gold or anything like stuff
like that
i wasn't an iraq during that time but i
know a few friends that
really was pretty great yeah so when you
were in iraq you didn't go into the
major cities it was more like
um in my second employment i was in
fallujah but my first one i was in
um the city called alkine or not city
but near on the outskirts of alkine it's
like on the
northern syrian border yeah iraq and you
were in fallujah though that that place
was pretty pretty crazy
fallujah was crazy in like phantom fury
which is like 2004 for the first one in
2005 for the second i was there in 2007
and 2008. so it was more stabilized more
stabilized a lot more
i was in the very center of the city
called this place called oaky burgess
yeah
um so we didn't see too much crazy stuff
just a lot of bombs
or like two police stations got leveled
though they drove two big
trucks with bombs in it and leveled it
are we still in there
iraq and afghanistan yeah um to a
certain limited capacity
we definitely are yeah uh do you know
like what we're trying to do over there
like trying to stabilize it or
do you know why oh man that's way above
my head but from what i
i know is um if we can under fully
understand the threat over there and
kind of keep the attention over there
it'll limit the
attention that they would put onto
american soil right so it's almost like
defense by offense
yeah um as well as trying to stabilize
the
area right as much as possible where
wherever we could provide assistance
especially in defense
um it would help from other regimes kind
of standing up and trying to
throw a coup on their own government on
so many different levels right like
the situation with syria and all that
stuff was like seven different power
players
all trying to come into it so we're just
trying to
figure out what's really going on
because if we don't have a presence
there we can't really figure it out we
just need to
send spies all the time which is a lot
of money and a lot of
assets going in to train one person in
bed em
you know so yeah but a military presence
there allows us to have access to a lot
more information and
understanding of the area there's a lot
going on that i have no idea
yeah me too brother that's that's what
you just said you're like i really don't
even barely know
yeah you just get a mission and you just
gotta do what you gotta do
[Music]
you